and the length of time that a technology
lasts has gotten so short if you invest
much into it
you're going to be disappointed so I
think if you're young if you're 18 or 20
it may not seem so strange to you that
something's over after six months but
when you're a little older than that it
it's a little bit unsettling to be not
even be able to light on something long
enough to even do something of any depth
or meaning before suddenly like that's
over sorry so that's one part of how
technology has changed in recent years
that I find a little unsettling and I
kind of hope that we'll reach a point
where
we can come up with something that's
lasting enough that somebody can do
something with a little bit of more
depth and a little bit less surface
because I feel like that kind of quick
change over of formats and
of software compatibility and all that
kind of stuff it really is kind of
lending itself to making people just not
be as deep because they're like why
invest in anything